hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I just got the crap scared out of me
a bottle of Gatorade just fell off my
desk randomly in this game is what Deku
I'm not even joking around it just like
as soon as I cut on the last part it
fell over and it scared the crap out of
me but anyway back into the game so
you're moving through how do I know this
hotel room is not haunted anyway I need
to go to the first floor to talk to
landlady about the person who lived here
before so it's a there's another crack
in the wall I wonder if that's gonna be
important hello miss landlady it's misty
David what seems to be the matter good
day miss I just wanted to ask you
something you say about the room um and
kind of haunted a lot of strange things
happen to me ah blood on the screen of
the TV well you know these apartments
are always have people coming and going
now what was that boy's name I believe
he was a Satan a devil incarnate a demon
man suddenly left about a month ago said
to leave the furniture and use it
however you wouldn't know where he went
I never heard that no really just up and
left out of the blue maybe he was a
smart one and left as soon as the blood
got pouring out of the walls I just
can't remember that name I could rummage
through my documents to find the
previous tenants if you'd like oh I'd
like no no yes yeah I was just a little
curious
Lara sorry I wasn't very useful well you
didn't even try David okay whatever ah
man my nose is running in I apologize is
disgusting um I'm just a huge slob a man
about my age I can only wonder oh well
I'll get back to my room if you say so
David I like how this one is just kind
of guiding me back in force I am
assuming that later on okay nope nope
nope no no don't see what all right
let's go I'm sure it's going right for
the crack in the wall I knew those
cracks in the walls would be something I
knew they would be it lead up to this
wall is there something in this crack uh
got a brass key
you too what I doubt it's for anything
in here so I wonder where mmm-hmm
the guy's voice the kid's voice is a
mirror on the writing the TV turning on
the coffee the Damon's the me being an
idiot it's like a poltergeist or
something would have thought the land
maybe would have mentioned this kind of
thing you mean ghosts hey by the way
when you're moving in here there's got
to be a good cook good co-host not that
I'd care if there were ghosts here I
wouldn't much care if they haunted me
and killed me either
whoo getting a little depressing there
guy but I wonder about that scrap of
paper what was the man who lived here
like did this stuff happen when he was
here maybe this guy is like a total
badass and he's just completely
indifferent to everything
he's not even cleaning up the footprints
on the floor this guy is like the most
hardcore son of a [ __ ] to ever walk
this side of the Pecos my god he's
fantastic he's not even scared he goes
out in the middle of the night he's like
me except I'm a big okay [ __ ] that okay
no oh that's a radio okay I have no idea
what that was outside like a growl where
that coming from is it from inside the
house oh yeah what the hell where's that
coming from
well where is it coming from I hear
something in the room in that room where
oh man this game is really giving me
chills up my spine easy it's just
combination cuz I'm in this room I know
and I'm a big baby I sorry oh man what
is going on
where's cover please go hike it huh
radio what's Wiser's in my closet not to
mention turning on by itself okay
I've also got the volume like way turned
up like I always do there's something on
this paper here it's an address our
special place
Oh got a paper with an address on it
well good for me can I go too ok don't
know better what are you doing wouldn't
know it what what the hell we're way um
I'm waiting for you look at little David
he's traveling he's traveling in his
booties what the hell I'm waiting food
I'm waiting up Wow finally got some
sense oh man
sprinted out of there like a big bubble
one baby like a shutout what the hell oh
my god yeah go to Paul so you slept well
last night sorry you had to sleep on the
couch now I should be sorry for coming
over so late huh wasn't expecting it but
don't sweat it but hey did something
happen you don't look so hot oh there's
no particular reason no maybe I felt
like intruding into the newlyweds love
nest
no why you guy just kidding are we not
gonna talk about that seriously though
you can tell me if anything happens I'll
do whatever I can for you alright glad
to have a buddy who looks out for his
friends even though I know you're kind
of a dick hey you make fun of me
no I heard from Marian sorry about the
Shirley thing I told her off for that
don't worry about it's not marrying
fault well it's not whose fault it is
I'm just not happy about it don't let it
get you down all right
I know you've got your mother to look
after but I think it's time you move on
and look for new people so it must be a
crazy ex as if a guy like me could find
a day hey I could show him I'm just some
clerk with a mom in the hospital the
girl I want to marry ran from me man
don't be such a [ __ ] you keep up that
moping and you'll have your own personal
rain cloud well I'll be careful
long so I'm going on a little trip to
always buy I don't want to waste my
vacation you know oh great idea we're
going a special place a very special
oh hi uh hi David William eating - now
I'm going to a special place with
sunshine and rainbows and all sorts of
wonderful things that everyone will want
to see there looks like these addresses
in the mountains about a five-hour drive
no we're not going to talk about what
just happened anyway did the former
tenant go there I just want to ask him
about this room maybe you'll know
something maybe he will maybe he will
not hell I'll go right now I can't stand
this place anyway let's go buddy Jim
this story I'm totally digging this
story it's like that was just a prologue
holy crap
yeah hell yeah that was only the
prologue man there's a great way to open
up for him it was really cool I loved
what they did it was awesome that was
just setting up the premise for it
I don't know how long this game is so uh
this may be a longer let's play but I'm
hoping to do it like just bang out a lot
of episodes I know you guys have been
lacking for content so I'm hoping that
this one is just gonna give you a lot of
content I'm really liking this story so
far I mean I love a game with a great
story Jesus got dark but this place no
doubt huge place looks like a hotel
would it be I heard some in the game I
swear to God if someone is [ __ ] with
me outside of my room I guess I'll have
to check it looks like a faded bored
hotel room I'm giving you a serene stay
oh god no oh god no I wonder how much
blood is gonna come pouring out of the
elevators in this hotel Oh what's this
the Bates Motel combined with that hotel
from the shining Oh Oh No thank you
it's locked clock is shafts landscape
painting staff room there's a wire
around the doorknob what does that even
mean okay
I guess I'm just checking the room won't
open I've got the brass key from a while
ago so I'm assuming that oh hello well
this is awfully ornate I'm gonna say
before something jumps out at me just
preemptively just saying there's
something on this treasure hunt
dear Mom and Dad is that like prop hunt
me treasure hunt I guess some kid
staying here drew this huh I'll look for
your treasure
what no why no no not at all okay so uh
I don't know what that means but it's
kind of a chop right thing has a crown
in it so maybe that I don't know
whatever I don't whatever no don't keep
looking on it it's not a paper it's
doesn't stop me okay
dressers empty how about the bed nothing
okay there's some weird wind rustling
through these walls Wimbley by brass key
can they work here I have a brass key
okay no huh I haven't even looked at my
inventory the entire time can i sprint
okay I can't even go any faster so I'm
stuck with the way I is what is it
sizing 107 to 1 or 101 to 107 all right
ooh that is sinister-looking a mounted
deer okay I'm gonna check the bottom
floor first just to knock it out and see
if I can what does it mean the keyhole
is painted over how do you paint over a
keyhole wouldn't you just be able to
bust through it okay it's locked okay so
none of these doors worked and I don't
think I can actually use the brass key
so I'll just know when I come across it
I guess I guess
hey a bar oh good I can drink away this
horrible nightmare oh come on
there's no sanctuary for me not even at
the bar drinking's bad okay kids show
bad until you turn 21 is so good oh oh
okay what's going on in this from a are
we gonna oh the treasure this is it
there's something under here yeah it
just looks like the thing I found a gold
key heck yes you found the treasure
Congrats
I mean I think this little kid is the
one that was crying in my in my
apartment how are this connected how are
this apartment in this hotel connected I
have no idea
oh boy Schubert three piano ages
oh that Vienna's gonna start playing
itself own it yep yep I know it calling
it right now okay so I got a gold key
and I got a brass key which means that I
can utilize them in some fashion to dues
ah here we go
hello oh oh I shouldn't have the volume
so high yeah okay there's a scrap of
notebook residual or was it say it was
our special place she loved the pretty
room with its big mirror she would
wonder what to wear for dinner but now
it's just me I thought it might help to
come here but it didn't there's only
emptiness the rule on this page it
matches the one from my room so the
former tenant did come here I wonder if
he's still here maybe he is The Crooked
Man
so he got dumped uh the note at home did
mention that and our special place he
came here with her and then he murdered
her dad where could he be dead or in the
walls in the cracks in the walls he's
everywhere and nowhere
okay I gotta find something I'm gonna
find something it's very subtle this
game those are the more we father
he's using goki oh boy let's go in hey
there's a gigantic ass key here key to
109 and key to one who nine the owners
collection of books please read at your
leisure okay cry of the unseen hi
cryotic was heared do you consider
yourself kind you don't get to decide
that it's decided in the unconscious
even if you believe you are cold-hearted
you may be warm and emotional inside and
they will sniff it out they will be
lured by your kindness and they will
drag you away some kind of a cult book I
that Paul would love this he's way too
into the stuff for his age okay oh yeah
what was that what was that holy sage
Luther what was that what was that don't
be don't be [ __ ] don't be [ __ ]
don't be [ __ ] with me don't you let on
don't you be [ __ ] with me you son of
a [ __ ] I will slap you in the face with
a back of my hand
I will cross your jaw with silver I
don't even know that mean I'll do it
look how many times I say I'm doing it
Oh pick the right one something on top
will get it can i push it air over there
yolk is this old mechanic hip now I can
keep the wets on the dresser come on
down wire cutters okay so I can get the
thing on the door okay I'm all out of
time for this part man I am I am really
liking I wish I had started doing RPG
horror games later because I really like
to play them they're really fun and
quite creepy for what they are
I lost me in an all towel rub really
creep me the [ __ ] out okay so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and has always I will see you in
the next video bye bye